Yo, yo, can you hear me?
>> Yep. Yep. What's your religion, man?
>> What's up, man? Um, I don't really So, I
don't have a religion, but I am I'm in a
scripture, so I believe, you know, um,
Christ is the only way, and I do believe
all of that. I just believe there's a
lot of pagan influence that's ignored
when that's in Christianity. It feels
like it's a very wide gate. And even
when you get to some of the church
leaders like that, I don't want to say
that you're glorifying that these people
were bad people. These people were
literally saying these Jews because they
have curses, they don't have the
covenant anymore. So we are the new
people of the covenant now. Um so we're
going to take their way. Um we're going
to twist it cuz that's what Satan does.
He twists the way. And
>> so you're a Christian?
>> No, not at all.
>> So what what what's your contention with
us? Aren't you a Christian? You said,
say it one more time. Why aren't you a
Christian?
>> Oh, because it's a I feel like it's a
formulated religion. I feel like the
followers were not called Christians at
all. They were just the followers of the
way. From what I seen, it was called the
Natsarim or
>> what?
>> The Natsarim.
But when I see Christians and I see like
the church leaders and the people who
formulated Christianity or like
Constantine, that was a terrible person.
Constantine was an awful, awful person.
>> No, he wasn't. He was probably one of
the best Roman emperors ever. He human
rights. He made manumission of slaves
easier. He got justice to the poor. He
passed laws on animal cruelty. If you
read the book called Defending
Constantine, Peter J. Lightheart
documents all this. Everything we know
about Constantine, most of it is just
from historical myths invented after the
fact.
>> Let me after one one more thing.
>> Let me go to you, brother.
>> So the church in Antioch, this is Acts
chapter 11. And it says, "So then those
who were set who were scattered because
of the persecution that occurred in
connection with Steven made their way to
Phoenicia and Cyprus and Antioch,
speaking the word to no one except to
Jews alone. But there were some of them
men of Cyprus and Sirene who came to
Antioch and began speaking to the Greeks
also, proclaiming the good news of the
Lord Jesus. And the hand of the Lord was
with them. And a large number who
believed turned to the Lord. Now the
news about them reached the ears of the
church at Jerusalem. And they sent
Barnabas off to Antioch who when he
arrived and saw the grace of God
rejoiced and became I'm sorry began to
encourage them all with a purposeful
heart to remain true to the Lord. For he
was a good man and full of the Holy
Spirit and of faith. And a considerable
crowd was brought to the Lord. And he
left for Tarsus to search for Paul for
Saul. And when he found him, he brought
him to Antioch. And it happened that for
an entire year they met with the church
and taught a considerable crowd. And the
disciples were first called Christians
in Antioch. So the followers of the way
were also identified as Christians.
>> Okay, good point. I have a question
about this.
>> Sure.
>> I feel like that doesn't explain after
the second temple destruction, the Roman
and Greek converts when they rose to
power, the church leaders were still
saying like Marcion and later
Constantine, they were openly declaring
that the Jews were wrong and they
separated their religion.
>> They was he was a bad person. And
Constantine Constantine did have Knights
Templar notes. He but what does this
have to do with the the gospel message
and the Christian scriptures right what
Jesus who Jesus was what he taught and
what the apostles them taught themselves
taught
>> because of this that's a good question
that's an amazing question because of
this I feel like it's the the way to see
things the way to decipher things the
way to look at evil and not look at
everything as you just like if when you
can't see the evil when you don't know
your enemy it's way easier to fall into
it and not basically not look upon the
chessboard and be on the chessboard
because there's a lot of evil. But
because Christians only believe in
grace, believe in salvation, they see
everything as just bright and good when
there's a deep deep evil that that the
Most High allows to happen to test us
and try us as gold. But there's a deep
evil that Satan is very smart. He's
going to take the way and he's going to
twist it so more people can follow that
way in our
>> Do you believe in the Bible?
>> Absolutely. just not Christmas, not
Easter, not all these pagan stuff.
>> Um, am I I don't believe that only Jews
will be saved and all of that, but I do
believe um African-Americans from the
tribe of Judah. Yes, I do believe that.
>> Okay. So, you believe in the scriptures.
So, you believe that you're saved by the
work of Christ and not things that you
do yourself that you have to rely on
Christ and his work to save you.
>> Wait, say that.
>> Jeez. I basically I believe that I'm
saved through the
>> My bad.
>> Yeah. So, so how do you believe how do
you believe that? Uh what what is the
what's the gospel message in the Bible?
>> I personally believe that um I am saved
you know through the blood of Christ and
through the eternal priesthood of the
son. You know basically you know the
basically the new thing between the old
covenant and new covenant. And basically
>> do you believe who do you believe that
Christ is?
>> God. He's the most high in the flesh. He
humbled himself and became.
>> So, you you agree with the trinity?
>> Yes, I'm still doing my research on it.
But yes, I am. I'm just it I was just
finding like some bad stuff with the
whole Babylon thing, but I I was looking
at inspired philosophy with his videos
about that. I know how you kind of don't
believe none of that, but like I do
believe in the trinity. I just believe
there was a a twisted version like you
know with the whole Babylon thing. At
first, I used to believe that it came
from Babylon, but I am starting to see
after watching your videos and stuff.
>> Okay, that's good. So you you affirm the
trinity. You affirm the work the
salvific work of Christ in the flesh.
You you affirm these things. So what
what what's what do you mean you're not
a Christian? I don't understand. Why are
you denying being a Christian when the
Bible calls us Christians?
>> Just the way it was formulated pretty
much. That's really it. It's the way it
was formulated.
>> We see what how it was formulated. It
was formulated by the apostles drawing a
lot of people to
>> Is that the Hebrew? Is that was that is
that um what is that the Hebrew
translation as well for that?
>> This is the New Testament. It's Greek.
It was not written in Hebrew.
>> No, I'm saying was there a different So,
hello.
>> Sorry guys. Keep getting kicked somehow.
>> Yeah, my bad. It just seemed like it
it's really like Hebrew mixed with a
little bit of Greek philosophy mixed
with a whole bunch of different stuff.
It just felt like that way when I was
when I'm looking at the scripture and
I'm looking at how Freemasons are trying
to twist certain things. It's It's kind
of hard to escape when you kind of see
like Christmas is pagan. Like
>> No, it isn't.
>> It is.
>> No, there's absolutely no evidence of
Christmas being pagan.
>> You can look up the Sergeant of Aad. Um,
this is
>> Sargon of Akad
>> or Sergeant of Aad. Excuse my
pronunciation. That was terrible. Sorry
about that. I butchered it. But, um,
>> I thought you said Sergeant. I'm like,
what?
>> He is Nimrod. He's a deifi. They He is
Nimrod. and they renamed him just like
they renamed him. Well, I feel like
that's where Christmas comes from.
That's why that's the point. That's the
point.
>> But there's no sources that talk about
Sargon of Akad having a holiday in
December 25th or worshiping a god on
December 25th.
>> But you're saying he founded the same
cities. He founded his wife. His wife
was called the queen. They worshiped
this. His wife was
>> You're getting all this from all this is
getting you're getting this all from a
guy called named Alexander Hislop. He
wrote a book called The Two Babylons. He
was a crazy Scottish preacher in the
1700s. No one takes him seriously. His
Sargon of Akad if you're saying is
Nimrod. His wife was not Semi Ramis.
Semi Ramis was probably an Assyrian
queen that lived after the time of
David. And then people just like
Diodoris talks about her. But Alexander
Hislap got all his sources confused and
thought he was the she was the wife of
Nimrod, projected her further into the
past and wrote this whole kooky book and
that his myths still perpetrated through
a lot of modern day culture today
unfortunately.
>> And what do you say about the eye womb
that you see with his mask? Because you
go to Josephus, it says how Shim killed
him and he took out one of his eyes and
you start to see with Gilgamish, he has
the same mask with one eye. Um with him,
you see the same depiction. He has the
same beard, the same mask. He has one
eye ripped out. Nam sin. You see the
same thing. He has a mask with the beard
with his eye ripped out. You start he
they're like it's like they're renaming
him. And I do believe that when Apolon
when they said in the scripture that the
beast wouldn't be named Apolon, he was
deified as Apollo. And that's where all
of the Christmas mithras Odin they're
all different versions of Nimrod. If you
read the book of Enoch and stuff in the
Jasher, you will understand this because
you have to read the book of Enoch. Man,
Kelly, you're getting all this from
Alexander Hislop. There is no ancient
sources that confirm this stuff.
Alexander Hislop made all this up. There
are no depictions of what you're talking
about. You're getting the depictions
confused with Assyrian kings that came
later. There there is no holidays. You
see them with the Catholics with the
Mary and the sun. That's Simus and
Tamuz. That's the statues that you see.
>> them darn Catholics. I knew it. I knew
it. You know, you did it again. You
Catholics.
>> Tamuz was a shepherd deity in ancient
Mesopotamia. His Sumerian name was
Damuzi. And there's no connection.
There's no depictions of him being held
as a child by Semi Ramis because again,
Semi Ramis is a queen from after the
year 100 BC.
>> But Babylon, it kind of confirms it
because when everybody dispersed, why
does Egypt have the same story as
Babylon with him getting Yes. Yes.
Josephus says that Nimrod got cut up in
the 24 pieces. What happened to I
believe was it Osiris? It's the same.
>> Josephus isn't that accurate in this
stuff either. He's also making stuff up.
He had parallelia often. He tried to do
a lot of the same stuff and then
Alexander Hop took it and ran wild with
it. But if you go back to the ancient
like the ancient texts that are in Cunea
form, the hieroglyphs from Egypt, none
of this is there.
>> Okay, I feel you. I I I 100% feel you. I
do still believe that the Apocrypha kind
of confirms this too. Even though I know
you guys might not agree with the book
of Enoch and stuff, but I think like if
you read Leviticus 16, you kind of have
to read the book of Enoch because that
word scapegoat is translated to a zazu,
which you can only find in the book of
Enoch. Hold on, my bad.
>> But I mean, yeah, that's this is this is
people that wrote the book of Enoch.
They're writing pseudopigria. They'll
see things in Leviticus and go, "Ooh, I
like that. Let me expand and make a
whole myth." This is why you probably
believe in the globe because that's sun
worship too.
>> Well, I certainly do believe in the
globe.
>> Read Manly P. Hall book um the secret
teachings of all ages. He kind of he he
tells you how that's literally sun
worship and it's Lucifer's world. That's
literally what it is. That's because
that's not biblical at all. And the book
of Enoch confirms that. It confirms
literally what it says with Genesis. And
it synchronizes Enoch 6, Genesis 6, but
it goes in more detail with what the
Nephilim did. Genesis.
>> Come on. Come on, bro. This is you
spitting, baby.
>> No, you see these are the church leaders
in your head. This is Christianity. This
is Christianity.
>> It's the Catholics, man. It's them darn
Catholics. They don't put this in your
head, man. Come on now. Ain't it
obvious? Enoch 6, Genesis 6, Isaiah 6.
You see, I think about Revelation 6.
What's the number of man? Six. What day
did God create mankind?
>> On the sixth day,
>> bro.
>> Bro, this is conspiracy stuff, man. I'm
telling you.
>> It's not, bro. I'm telling you.
>> Okay, let me ask you a simple question.
Okay, let's just go to Genesis 6 for a
minute. You think the Nephilim are like
like half breeds, right? They're like
half
>> fallen angels made it with women. And
when they made it with women, they
created hybrid species and the women
turned to mermaids or sirens. That's
what happened.
>> Okay. Then why does it call them men?
>> Why does Genesis 6 call them men?
>> Bro,
>> it says these these are the mighty men
of old, the men of renown. And it's when
it says men of renown, okay, it's again
just says men, not half breeds, not half
angels. Even the sons of God in verse
two are called men in verse three
because
>> Oh, those are archons. Those are those
are
>> called them that. Where's it called?
>> Enoch. Enoch.
>> Not in the book though. that's in a much
later book written in like the 2n
century BC or later. Like like this is
stuff that's much later, man. This is
stuff that Genesis is old. Enoch is not.
People writing fanfiction on Genesis.
That's what Enoch is. Jubilees. It's
fanfiction.
>> That's what you think? I don't know. I
feel like it synchronizes I feel like it
synchronizes pretty well like with the
fallen angels. It basically and it it
says it was written for us
>> fanfiction. They were trying to do that
when they were writing the fanfiction.
when they wrote Jubilees, when they
wrote the books, it became the book of
Enoch. Cuz that wasn't one book at one
point. That's a cannon of various books.
>> It was really the church leader. The
church leader saw that that Judah was
literally jumping over buildings,
destroying cities. And they were just
like, "This can't be real." And these
people, these slaves, no, these slaves
can't know that these people that were
from them were doing this. So, we have
to take these books out and make the
slave bible and make these other
variants. So, we need to control these
slave. And there it is again. You see
what I'm talking about? It's called King
James Slaves Bible.
>> King James Slave Bible. You know, guess
what? You know King James was a
Catholic,
>> bro.
>> He was a Catholic. A black Catholic at
that. Did you know that? You didn't know
that? King James was a negro Catholic
and he done wrote all these books and
brought out the slave Bible. See, now I
got this brother behind me laughing
because his church leaders is in his
head. You see that?
>> Never go full moon.
>> Never. You can't you can't escape the
quotes from these church leaders. These
Jews don't know what they're talking
about. They don't know the true way.
>> Exactly. Hey man, thanks for shedding
your light on this stage, man. For real.
You brought you brought that wisdom,
that hikma. In Arabic, we call it hikma,
man. So, I appreciate that, man.
>> All right. Thank you. I still respect I
of course respect you. Uh, I think y'all
got the Holy Spirit working through
y'all. I appreciate y'all content and
everything. I appreciate the
conversation and thank y'all. Keep
going.
>> Yes, sir, man. Yes, sir. Peace, bro.
>> That was like the Tik Tok come to life
into
>> Yeah. All the uh Tik Tockers fused
together. They said, "Man, let's do it.
>> I have to deal with that stuff all the
time on Tik Tok. It's all a bunch of
nonsense."
>> It's It's interesting though because Ken
believes in the Bible, but is also a
huge conspiracy theorist with all this
other stuff. It's really interesting,
man. Really, really interesting, man.
>> I mean, like, yeah, here's Oh, I should
have mentioned this here. Here, Cam, if
you're still listening, the book of
Enoch is heretical
>> because it says in the middle of Enoch,
it says Enoch is the son of man, the
Messiah. Now, RC Charles translated that
as this is the son of man because he
didn't think that that Enoch should be
identified as the son of man. But in in
the manuscripts that we have, it always
says like the Ethiopian manuscript and
the fragments from earlier, uh I'm not
sure if it isn't in the fragments, but
in the manuscripts we have of it, it
always says Enoch is the son of man.
That's heretical because it goes against
what the New Testament teaches that
Jesus is the Messiah. But in the book of
Enoch, Enoch is the Messiah. That's it's
heretical. You got to throw it out. It
is not compatible with the New
Testament.
>> Nice. All right. GG, you're on stage,
man. How you doing?
>> Hello. Can you hear me?
>> Yes. How are you doing?
>> Good. How you doing?
>> Pretty good. How are you?
>> I'm fine. I just uh got a quick uh one
question for you. I just presented it a
picture. Can you see?
>> I can see that you presented something
but I can't read it. What does it say?
>> It was uh I just asked from a Muslim
friend and he just said uh about
something. Uh it shows in the picture.
He said, "Which one should I follow from
above above all of these?"
>> And what does he say? What? Like, give
me some examples that's on it. Cuz I I
don't I don't know you. I don't know. I
can't see that. So, I don't know if it's
something weird. So, just tell me what's
on it.
>> You cannot see.
>> No, I can't see it. It's too small for
me.
>> It's uh Wait, let me
>> just just read it out for me. What's
What's on it?
>> Okay. Okay. It's uh about the books. Uh
Samaritan
>> Samaritan Samaritan. The Samaran
penitent
>> yes five books and Jewish Hebrew Bible
contains 24 books and Protestants uh
canon Luther's
66 books Catholic canon 73 books Eastern
and Oriental Orthodox canon 76 books
Ethopian Orthodox canon 81 books and he
just said uh which one we should go uh
from all of these
>> so which book which can Yes. Which is
>> So do you want the history behind all
this to explain what's going on here?
>> Yes. Uh a answer will be better. What
should I uh I mean how can I answer him
if I want to tell him about this?
>> Yeah. So in the Catholic and Orthodox
Bible they have additional books which
they call dudero canonical. Uh means
second cannon basically. Uh and so the
reason why they're dudero canonical is
because the original Tanakh that the
Jews used did not include them. This was
identified by the church father Jerome
when he translated the Hebrew scriptures
into the Latin Vulgate. He translated
the the Old Testament as Protestants use
now. And so during the Reformation,
Martin Luther and the other reformers
were like, "We don't need the dudero
canonical. They're not necessary for
teaching what the faith is." So they
just left them out. That's kind of the
basic reasoning behind it. And the the
Orthodox and Catholics would say is that
the duderoical books are still helpful
for teaching certain doctrines that they
would hold to in church, but they're not
essential Christian doctrines. That's
the dividing line.
>> Okay. Uh can I get a link so I can share
this stuff?
>> A link?
>> That's just from my head.
>> I mean like what uh should I tell him?
>> Why don't you just uh tell him what I
told you? You can play the stream back,
listen to it, and then just say that.
>> Okay. Anything else other than this?
>> No. I mean, that's all your answer your
question. I mean, if he's trying to
argue that this is a problem, it's not.
We don't have the same view as scripture
that the Muslims do. We don't say that
the Bible is the uncreated speech of
Yahweh. These are inspired books to
teach the faith. And so, we have books
that are necessary to teach the faith.
And then we include those as part of our
canon. We say they're inspired by the
Holy Spirit and so we include books that
teach the faith.
>> Okay. Thank you so much.
>> Yep. So make sure you watch this back
this segment back. This is about three
hour the three-hour mark in 8 minutes.
So yes, come back to this and just
rewatch it, absorb it and uh and also
look into look into the details on your
own. Like look into the details of
>> the what was it? The Samaritan Pentatuk
like these things that he listed. Look
into those details yourself so you can
be aware of exactly what those things
are. Yes, I have been watching your
videos. I got so much information from
you.
>> Praise God.
>> And I'm also I mean like talking about
this and uh telling about him about the
Bible and he's also interested on this
on this all stuff. You know what I mean?
So, praise the God. Uh
>> yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Sounds good.
>> Thank you.
>> Of course, brother. God bless you, man.
>> Hey, you know what? The Jews never
included as part of the Tanakh.
>> What? They never include
>> Enoch. And you want to know why? Because
them was some Catholic Jews. Them Jews
that didn't include the book of Enoch
and the Tanakh. See Enoch, Tanak. The
reason why they didn't put it in there
because those Jews were Catholic. Don't
be deceived by your church leaders. I'm
telling you, we shining that light
around here. What's the only thing we do
around here, y'all? What's the only
thing we do? We just read. That's the
truth. Then I be alive.
You make a great Southern Baptist
preacher.
>> Oh, thank you, man. Thank you. Thank
you.